welcome back to las vegas now we are
wilding out with comedian chico bean
he's hanging with us right before he
hits the stage at the mirage this
saturday for aces of comedy welcome
hello how are you
thank you for having me we we're already
besties because he said um rocky you
have a little margarita salt on your
mouth
on her lip i couldn't let her get on tv
like the previous
segment because i'm a good man yeah
exactly exactly that's what we like to
hear now okay so let's first and
foremost talk about your name yes chico
bean yes where did that come from well
it's kind of unique so being is my
bean is my real last name that's my last
name now when i was making my twitter
account you know how when you're trying
to pick a name and they say name already
taken so i was like what it must be
already on twitter so my guy was like
nah i got to be creative so chico is a
childhood nickname you know i mean when
i was young i used to try to dress up
like my uncles when they would go to the
club and they would call me little chico
because i would have on the oshkosh we
got short set with the penny loafers and
they would call me little chico so chico
yeah all the way you know i get it from
them so they're still giving a little
chico no still yeah but it's not that
unique then that's what it is no but
it's you
it was meant to be you were meant to be
chico me all the way thank you and and
your career you know really took off
when you did while in out yes yes what
was it like being on that show what does
that show mean to you um it's comedy
camp yeah you know that's the best way i
can explain it it's comedy camp you got
all these different personalities you
know some people who are comedians some
people who aren't you have some rappers
but we all come together and make a
product that people love you know when
we first came back we didn't really know
what the you know spectrum was going to
be of how far we would go we just knew
we was on tv and we wanted to be on tv
and it is turning us up and we coming up
on season 19 and 20 now i came in season
five so it's been a success it's been a
success all thanks to nick cannon no i
mean yeah what's it like with him you
know we get the a lot of other
perspectives what's the perspective of
being one of his communities
i mean that's interesting
perspective
oh yeah all the other okay i see what
you're saying all right but uh no [ __ ]
[ __ ] a great dude man you know he
one thing i say about him is a lot of
people who give opportunity don't stand
beside you while they give it to you and
he's still beside us and let us joke on
them and talk about them the whole time
so that you have to have a certain level
of uh you know just self-worth to even
be in that position in this business you
have a lot of people who are secretly
you know i mean uh what's the word i'm
looking for when you when you i'm having
a brain fog
um help me ma'am
uh insecurity come on man we're both
college educated people it took me that
long to get there he majored in
journalism by the way so i would have
been able to read it but i couldn't
think of it just yeah a lot of
insecurities in the industry so for him
to not be insecure and that allow us to
use his name and his likeness to get to
the points that we've been able to get
to is a blessing he seems like a great
guy and and for you you know i want to
read this properly i heard that you have
the ability to memorize old songs almost
instantly well not all not old songs
just songs that i like you know i mean i
don't want to just but it's like you
could throw on some you catch it real
good i can catch a real especially if i
like it and quirky jingles you can
create on the spot yeah corky can can
you do one right now we're gonna put you
on the spot you're gonna put me on i
want you i want you to create a jingle
in your head right now about your show
at aces of comedy okay but keep it clean
keep it clean
that's a little different um it's not
well now um okay uh aces is a comedy
you're definitely gonna trip but just
make sure you don't have no crust on
your lips there you go
there it is you see we did it just that
quick man i am impressed
all the way you know i'm proud that my
margarita salt could give me yeah you
got to be inspirational
what can they expect at the show
saturday mirage ace of the comedy whole
bunch of fun man you know um vegas is a
big opportunity i mean you know it's a
blessing to be here you know this is one
of the meccas of entertainment so for me
to even be on my own show and have my
own marquee in in the mirage hotel is
just you know what i mean is is a
blessing so the casino everybody if
you're there if you're gambling if you
lose your money i can make you feel good
if you win some money i can make you
feel good if you're just looking ahead
margarita dustin on your face if you
like my man over there get ready wait he
waiting on his turn right he got to
he wait no he is ready
you can't see me over there ready
wrap it up
he was reading he was reading out loud
and everything so i think we got to slow
down so my man can get right but it's
going to be dope so make sure you get
your tickets to come see
chico the mom man kobe thank you so much
it was a pleasure you're performing
again in the aces of comedy series at
the mirage saturday august 6th that is
tomorrow 10 p.m tickets start at just
29.99 and can be purchased at mirage.com
jc
thank you rocky thank you chico i
appreciate it
you come over here get over here come on
come on this is honor you can roast me
if you want to
you can roast me no i don't want to
roast you
okay a new live music experience is
hitting las vegas we meet the singer and
learn about her vegas connections okay
one more keep going joe